make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are finally getting around to
the Marauders and I know I promised
somewhat or at least I said I would do
it last week I got super tied up and
super distracted there were a lot of you
guys know there were a lot of things
going on but uh but we're cover
Marauders right now here's here's the
thing here's what's going on with Don
impacts Don effects may or may not have
a singular cohesive storyline that
unites everything it may have that they
may end up kind of building up to that
or whatever the case is the reality is
that at the moment dawn of X is a
branding initiative right so think of it
like dark rain dark rain was not a story
or I guess it kind of was a loosely
based story arcs around you're evolving
Norman Osborn
basically taking over shield and then
dismantling it and replacing it with
hammer his own company and so on and so
forth but by and large dawn effects is a
branding initiative meaning that is
basically designed to signify a relaunch
of the various characters right so it's
like heroes reborn from back in the day
and so the idea behind this is that this
is designed to basically give us like
whole new titles and whole new teams and
Marvel's dumping them like gangbusters
it's insane within the span of like two
to three weeks we got Marauders and then
we get Excalibur we get x-force we get
followed angels we get all kinds of
stuff coming out of this like it's
insane all the content that they're
dropping and it's gonna be like like
something something new is coming out
every week and so we're gonna cover it
every week but it's kind of bonkers
anyway Marauders this is kind of
interesting because when I first saw
this my immediate thought was the exact
same as pretty much everybody else who's
been reading x-men for any real measure
of time and it was like the Marauders of
mr. sinister right it was like okay so
like we're doing a book about mr.
sinister and Marauders but then they
released the roster for and I was like
this is not mr. Sinister's Marauders
this is about as far as you get from mr.
Sinister's Marauders I'm like I'm kind
of down with that right cuz they got to
omega-level mutant Zhaan they're right
you got storm and you got Iceman and
honestly I kind of think Bishop can be
omega-level if they if they adjust his
powers like if they tweak his powers a
little bit but even absolutely they have
three they have Emma Frost on the team
as well so it's like do this is this is
kind of nuts but what this does is this
initially picks up with basically the
mutants grabbing some mutants who
basically gathered together in in
Central Park New York and then leading
him into one of the one of the gates of
krakoa now remember we covered this
during house and powers of X so I'm not
gonna go super hardcore into this but
the idea here is that in order for the
mutant mutant land right in Eaton
country of krakoa to be able to like
grab different mutants of different
locations and bring them in at any point
in time gates can be sprouted up now a
lot of those gates were created
artificially by krakoa in different
locations because of the fact that it
was so huge right like Russia's a huge
place these gates crop up they they
probably would ever look
and then basically mutants are led in
you know led through those gates into
the island of cacoa now I remember
kokoa can decide who gets in and who
doesn't get in but at the same time the
gates also function in such a way that
if you're not a mutant you can't access
it and the problem with this is that
when Kitty Pryde he goes to walk through
the gate she breaks her nose when she
basically hits what's essentially just
solid material and this can go a couple
different ways it can go in the form of
the fact that Kitty Pryde is not a
mutant and can't access it which begs
the question how in the world should you
ever manage to pass through him before
or crook who is not letting her through
and if Kirk Row is not letting her
through then the question becomes why
why is Greco and not letting her through
the gates and that's kind of the
question being asked here because what
this does is it basically leads to Kitty
Pryde really sometime later on longside
her dragon Lockheed heading towards this
island where all these mutants are
basically you know doing their thing
they're having like a great big huge
party is really what's gonna be going on
but she still can't access the gates
here and that's where the story starts
to shift right that's where the story
begins to shift here and the reason why
is because with Kitty Pryde being on a
van unable to access these gates and
well it's not really being given a
definitive answer as to why then one of
the things we find out of course is that
she was basically running like it like
Aaron's a Wolverine it's kind of crazy
because like Wolverine comes running out
of nowhere right he's like kitty did you
get all the stuff and she's like yes I
got it all so it's like won the world of
Wolverine one you comes back with like
beer in a case of whiskey and it makes
sense right like like so so you end up
getting this grocery list right like
Logan's shopping list right so you get
ribs from rendezvous in Memphis
I've never even heard of the restaurant
there's Canadian Club whisky which I've
never had beer Cubano sandwiches which I
have had and they're amazing there's
prom aid there's coffee like basically
she's just running like a smuggling
operation more or less at fur Wolverine
but the story really begins to shift and
it begins to pick up when she's
telepathically contacted by Emma Frost
and the reason why is because if you
guys recall during our videos on house
and powers of X the idea behind having
basically like this sort of black market
trading system for the different
medicines and things like that of
krikawa was to really operate in two
fronts the first was for a mutants to
basically wholly engineer this kind of
trading system right so there would be
the front side of the selling process
which is to say all the countries out
there that basically support poor koa
and say like we support what it is a
mutants ones do they're the ones who are
going to be able to buy the medicines
and the various things er kokoa can
offer in order to improve the lives of
humanity those who don't support Cocola
don't get any of that stuff right which
i really agree with right you know i
really agree with it but in order to
kind of keep things in somewhat of an
equitable balance the mutants are also
the ones controlling the black
so they kind of control the price of
goods on the black market in order to
ensure there's kind of a going back and
forth but the reality of this is that by
creating a black market and basically
saying those of you guys who do not who
who publicly do not support for Cola but
privately want to get your hands on
their medicine then we can do that for
you now they don't really know it's the
mutants who were pulling the strings
they don't really know is the mutants
who are doing it as far as they're
concerned it's some shady clandestine
organization or group somewhere this
making all this happen but because the
fact is a lot of these countries that
don't support krakoa are in turn keeping
their mutant population captive by
serving as kind of a black market
shipping company what it also does is it
gives them access to those underground
places that aren't really letting them
in population go and so because that by
operating is kind of a black market
organization it gets them into places
they wouldn't normally be able to get
into and then in turn they can liberate
the mutants in that particular
geographical location so it's a pretty
smart move but it's underhanded as
health but it's a pretty smart move and
that's the really the proposition that
Emma Frost had pitched to Kitty Price
like is this something that you want to
be a part of and Kitty Pryde have been
thinking about it for quite some time
but ultimately Emma Frost responses I
need a definitive answer here I need to
know are you in or are you out that's
what we kind of get this revelation that
there are all these different places
Russia so on and so forth in Brazil they
have these kind of hounds that basically
track down mutants or at least keep
mutants are being able to access the
gates but these gates and different
locations are all cordoned off by
military officials or government
officials or what-have-you and they're
not letting people get through they're
not letting their mutant population
leave now for some places for example
Russia when Bobby Drake goes there and
Bobby Drake is immediately attacked in
some cases it's because mutants are used
right we talked about it and I talked
about that in our video on Colossus
explained that when Colossus first
developed his powers his powers started
popping up at a time when Russia wasn't
exterminating their their Leaton
population instead they were fortunate
in meeting population to work as
soldiers of the Russian military hence
the winter guard but the work Colossus
was safe from that fate a lot of newtons
weren't and so what that basically man
is love Russia basically managed to get
their hands on a lot of super-powered
beings and they forced them to work for
the Russian government that's what's
going on here that's why there's
opposition here when Bobby Drake shows
up it's like no no no all super-powered
beings are basically tools of the state
they work for us they do what we tell
them to we're not letting them go like
we're not letting you guys you know walk
away from all this at the same time
there's some plot threads that are
thrown in here right like the you end up
going to Taiwan end up going to Taipei
and you end up having this this woman
who basically gets out in front of the
news cameras and everything and says my
husband went through one of those gates
and he vanished and what happened to him
and I don't know what's going on with
him and you have Bishop who shows up
it's
look we're investigating your husband
disappearance we don't have any record
of him entering through the gates of any
any of the gates in Taipei so like
obviously the implication seems to be
she's lying these are plot four is that
Jerry dude is gonna build up over time
but it's a cool little moment here so
it's a cool little scenario to see like
these little things throw it in you're
thrown out here and there in terms of
people who are lying about what's going
on people who are trying to curtail
public opinion to achieve a particular
goal it's a pretty smart move but from
here what it does is it switches over to
the reintroduction of pyro now when it
comes to the character of pyro in Marvel
comic sort of in a couple different
versions there's a version that anybody
who ever watched x-men the animated
series or has been reading x-men for a
long long time or aware of which is st.
John allerdyce it was I'm pretty sure
that's how you pronounce his name
then there's Simon Lasker who's the most
recent version this one here is st. John
right this is the the classic version of
pyro in an effort to kind of clean up a
lot of characters that were deemed as
kind of unnecessary or to rework them or
something like that
Marvel either got rid of them or they
basically soft rebooted them with the
character of Saint John he died in 2001
right he was removed in cable number 87
he ended up coming back a few years
later during the action approaches
storyline but was killed off yet again
and so as a result of that what you have
now is this this classic version back
here again but he's not really as brutal
as his old-school version instead this
it's a lot more lighthearted now that's
one of the things about how GRE dude is
right in this story and I hope is one of
the things you've noticed so far is this
as far more lighthearted than like a lot
of the other stories that we've seen
right it's not nearly as serious and
tone is like Jonathan Hickman
storytelling that's the nature of Jerry
Dugan and his little reasons why he's
shined so spectacularly when he wrote
Deadpool at least I loved his handling
of Deadpool but it's one of the reasons
why it was kind of like when you read
the Infinity Wars storyline Jerry Dugan
does better with like light-hearted and
comedic stories and he does with like
dark and and hardcore stories that's
always kind of in my take on him and so
as a result of that that's why this
story seems a lot lighter than you would
normally expect as one of the reasons
why right off the bat storms like well
one you're drafted onto this team and
two you can't kill people
you can't kill humans which is kind of
what he's always done right I mean he
has no love for Humanity now what are
the other other things that I want to
kind of clear up here is the nature of
Pyro's powers because doesn't become
important as we get further and further
into what's essentially gonna be the
Marauders comics and and Marvell pyro he
does not have the ability to create fire
he can't do that
what pyro can do is control existing
fire now sometimes it's amplifying the
size of that fire why did you take
what's basically a candle and expand it
out into this
beacuse that he'd do all kinds of stuff
create all kinds of different designs
and all kinds it's very very intricate
in terms of his ability to do that but
it's why you see him walk around with
basically flamethrowers attached to him
because he can't actually create fire
that's not really what he does it'd be
cool if he did because that he would be
overpowered as hell but he can't
actually make it so it's kind of
something you do you sort have to go
with now having said that and the power
of pyro is still pretty cool but what
really comes out of this this is really
the the big thing that focused on here
is the power of KT Prime and the reason
why is because Kitty Pryde is probably
one of the most underrated of the x-men
in terms of what you could really do
like if you if you really pull out the
stops and if you give us a story like
what we're getting ready to see right
here works like okay so Kitty Pryde has
always kind of been the cheerleader of
the x-men until she wasn't until she
graduated it became kind of like one of
the leaders of the team and different
things like that but no one's ever
really shown what she's truly capable of
like this does and is absolutely amazing
and the reason why is because what you
have there is one of these Russian guys
he basically uses a solar dampening suit
and so when it comes to him being able
to touch anybody out there being able to
blast storm or Iceman like it'll damn
for their powers it'll take their powers
away temporarily but the issue is that
contact has to be made with Kitty Pryde
it doesn't work that way so the first
thing she does is of course she phases
this she gets up to the guy takes him
down and that guys immediately out of
the picture from there she
single-handedly dismantled every single
soldier like she basically like either
either she's like they face to her and
she knocks them out there's a couple
there's one time where she basically
like shoots guys with bullets which is
kind of cool I mean shooting them is not
the biggest thing ever but the cool one
of the coolest moments is she grabs a
gun she phases it into two guys legs and
makes it solid again and so he they
basically got like a gun in their legs
were just kind of screwed up she phases
into a tank she rips grenades out of out
of out of the sky
you know she steals a sword from another
guy after incapacitating him it seems
kind of kind of like okay whatever this
is like a small little thing but here's
the thing you can't hit what you can't
touch and that's why Kitty Pryde is
probably one of the most powerful of the
x-men is it's the reason why if you read
the story Wolverine um enemy of the
state the what-if story where he
basically kills all the superheroes in
the Marvel Universe it isn't being Kitty
Pryde as it when it takes him out
because of what uses the ability to to
slash through anything with adamantium
claws if you can't touch it that's one
of the coolest things about Kitty Pryde
is like in this moment you kind of get
her as his character words like she can
take all comers and it's kind of a cool
thing because I mean the only way to
really get around that is to kind of
wear her down right to the point where
she's exhausted and she can't really
keep going anymore because it's just too
much for her to take mental or physical
or whatever the case happens to be but
of course pyro ends up channeling the
the
of Lockheed and then in turn you know
using dragon's breath basically like
spray down a whole bunch of guys it's
pretty cool it's pretty awesome and so
as a result of this like one of the one
of the people that they're liberating
has like an iPhone which kind of begs a
question like if they're stuck in a camp
why they have an iPhone but still like
one of the people has it has an iPhone
basically and is recording this mentions
of Kitty Pryde issues and it's kind of
it's kind of cool right because it
reminds me of the a-team like it's like
if you're a mutant and you can't get to
krakoa
then the Marauders will bring you home
right like worthy 18 it's kind of how it
feels right it's kind of how it comes
across and that's that's why I love the
Marauders so much because it's not a
super like y'all man things are popping
off everything is going crazy it's just
a good old-fashioned fun read and that's
really what it should be right the
nature of comics it's not the politics
right it's it's the the enjoyment of the
comics like it's fun reading this story
that's the cool that that's one of the
reasons why I love them more honors it's
fun it's just a fun story to read and
I'm really excited to see where it goes
like I'm really excited to see what
happens especially if they start
encountering like these super Opie
broken mutants like these these super
broken mutants so what you end up
getting is once they leave
Kitty Pryde starts addressing storm and
when she's talking to storm one of the
things to understand here is she's not
addressing storm as a member of the
x-men she's addressing storm as a
surrogate mother and the reason why is
because if you haven't if you haven't
been reading x-men for a long time and
something that it's kind of easily
missed something that you're not really
familiar with but when Kitty Pryde first
showed up in the x-men she was like 15
years old I think and so basically with
the character of storm she became a kind
of mother for Kitty Pryde right like
helping her navigate the waters of what
it meant to become a woman when she was
changing and she was going through this
biological process in terms of her body
you know growing and so on and so forth
a lot of the lessons that Kitty tried to
learn over the course of her life that
led her to becoming the superhero she is
today
were taught basically to her by storm
and so the relationship between the two
is very much mother and daughter and
it's one of the reasons why Kitty Pryde
basically tells storm I need you to stay
here I need you with me like I need you
to stay with me here while I'm while I'm
going on all this but really probably
two of the closest friends and so of
course following that the Marauders are
completely in fully form right you've
got pyro you got Kitty Pryde you got
Iceman and you got storms so right off
the bat you already got two omega-level
mutant here which is gonna make the team
an absolute powerhouse and absolute like
boss of a team is this kind of nuts but
uh but yeah I love it like I really
really really like this so the next one
we'll get into after this is going to be
Excalibur which is basically the return
of gambit and rogue I'm excited about
this
whatever you said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
two comments explain make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of
or if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]